good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday we hope
everyone had a fabulous fabulous
fabulous holiday weekend and hopefully
it was something like Kelly's mindless
news who like the fourth of July I hope
that it was that for you too I
personally had a fabulous weekend it was
just so much fun in the Sun I love Fun
in the Sun it was truly a fun-filled
weekend for me yeah
before we even say anything we wanted
which a very happy birthday to our
amazing sister Olivia
it is her 29th birthday and we just love
you so much it went to wish you happy
birthday we hope you have the best day
ever and we will ensure that you do we
will make it our mission cadet Kelly to
make sure that you are having the best
day ever we love you so much she's
already having the best day ever because
she's with presh Kayla Kayla yeah and
that's just it doesn't get better than
that every moment I'm not with prashila
is like a waste of time and energy and
space
I completely agree it's just [ __ ]
depressing to be without her I agree but
we'll be with her today and that's all
we can really ask for the aunt life is
the life for me
the aunt is it oh my god I almost just
choked I had a fabulous weekend yours
looked fabulous as well yeah I loved
watching you know Jackie O Flo make a
return to that great outdoors yeah no
she's miss the great outdoors it was
really just a fun weekend and it's
obviously been a while since I had one
of those um and I feel renewed like when
a singer I feel renewed exactly and I I
was I was in the Hamptons with my
in-laws and I was supposed to come back
yesterday but I decided to come back
Sunday um because I felt like I just
needed a day like to recover and
yesterday was probably one of the most
relaxing days I've had like in my life I
watched so much TV I've slept just like
I was in and out of sleep like the whole
day I was just exhausted I don't even
know from what but it was just a lovely
way to spend a Monday I'm glad that we
took the show off yesterday I feel like
I really needed that day off yeah I
appreciated it appreciated it as well
but this week I have people working in
my apartment because remember on the
patreon behind-the-scenes um my Home
Tour remember got my showers like broken
mm-hmm so I'm finally getting it fixed
but it had to wait until like we were in
phase construction phase right um so
there's all these people in
my apartment working and I can't get
into my bathroom which is why I was
disgusting today how beautiful I look
horrible I didn't have hairspray tint on
my curling iron I didn't know what to do
with myself and so I don't even know
what this dress is like just don't look
at me yes just don't look at Jackie look
beautiful stunning and smart I look ugly
stupid enough well we have a fabulous
show for you guys today there was so
much news over the weekend it was later
news killing me not to just talk about
all of it so we are going to be
recapping it all clamoring to get into
the Fast Five say like usually it's kind
of an open door policy yes something say
am i interesting and we'll talk about
you yeah but today we are making hard
cuts because like we really have the
Fast Five see the Fast Five and then we
are going to recap our toasts movie of
the week which was Selma and then we're
also gonna assign our new one and then I
watched a ton of stuff over the weekend
I want to talk about we both watched a
David Foster documentary I caught up on
Real Housewives of New York
and there's oom confessionals oh I
haven't watched out yet I've been trying
to finish a season four of Real
Housewives of Potomac
but I also didn't watch that much TV
this weekend because I was enjoying the
great outdoors and it was fabulous and I
encourage you all to try that you know
it's a beautiful thing to step outside
and just like enjoy yeah to step outside
breathe it in before we dive in I just
wanted to give a quick note to everyone
who watched my special this weekend it
really stayed on the home page of iTunes
for pretty much the entire weekend which
is crazy because if you really see movie
from like a movie studio obviously like
you can just pay to be on the home page
but we really sit independently so it
was on the home page because that many
people were watching it which was just
fabulous and I really really hope
everyone liked it and I'm so glad that
everyone watched it rent it bought it
the comedy album is now out so if you
listen to this podcast and you just like
listening to stuff as opposed to
watching you can aus listen to the album
which is available to stream on Spotify
or on iTunes Amazon music all the places
so great for a podcaster totally I have
something to say because I watched your
special oh my god you really just
kidding me I watched your special this
weekend it's the group that I was with
hmm in Claudia hilarious group it was
the best thing I've ever seen in my life
really like I wasn't expecting like to
be wowed because I've seen the show so
many times I was there when you film the
special um I was truly rolling on the
floor it was just so funny like my god
things were making me laugh the old
things are always making me laugh
like we were I was just laughing so hard
he was so [ __ ] enjoyable oh and I
just really I was shocked by the fact
that I was so moved by it considering
like I know what backwards and [ __ ]
we're desensitized it was just so funny
like you guys have you haven't watched
it yet or even if you've been to a show
like that's not a reason not to watch it
because it's also when you're sitting in
the audience you don't get all of your
facial expression yes and so with the
camera close-up on you like it really
does a great service to the whole comedy
yeah and it was just sensational when we
turn it on I was like so tired I was
like I'm gonna fall asleep and it was
just it was riveting wow I love that a
rave review from a really harsh critic
no I'm not harsh and I like everything
you do is great but I was just like
enamored by it it was so [ __ ] good
thank you so you guys it's eighties time
you have to watch it Gigi's time but it
is also time for something else yeah I
think it is time for the fast side
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast say that was like a little
different inflection you said that with
some uncertainty are you feeling okay
just like trying sometimes I improv with
it like you yeah you yeah yeah and I was
just sort of stuck between should I go
there should I not yes don't stay I just
stumbled over everywhere it was
beautiful nonetheless um before we dive
in I have to tell you like I saw the
funniest thing in the street yesterday
it wasn't funny was actually sad but
like you know when you can't stop
watching like a mess so this kid it was
raining and the kid was skateboarding
which like what are you doing
skateboarding in the rain and I already
know the course he just completely fell
on his ass and like everyone on the
block stopped to watch him which was
just like mortifying for him and he just
like was so defeated that he just like
let his skateboard roll down the
sidewalk but it eventually beard off the
sidewalk him into the street and a bus
came and it was crazy like within an
inch of the skateboards life like the
bus made it and then the bus I mean then
the skateboard went underneath something
like Toyota Camry and the person didn't
realize so the kid goes running and he's
like waiting and it looks like he's
going to get the skateboard you know it
was just so like he's gonna get it it's
not gonna get it and literally this tray
in a Camry like just starts driving an
inch and it runs over the skateboard but
half the skateboard so now the kid is
trying to get the skateboard from
underneath the wheel of the Toyota Camry
it was
so dramatic I was literally standing on
the corner for 20 minutes watching this
kid suffer like I obviously should have
offered to help but like when I'm
feeling embarrassed like if I fall
somewhere I want nobody to look at I
just like everyone to pretend like they
haven't seen yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
the nicest thing you could do it was
just such a like it was a series of
unfortunate events that's really sad
yeah and I'm not used to seeing things
on the street because in the last four
months all I've seen is uh someone
peeing on a pay phone booth I saw that
the other day I was so crazy I've
actually seen now twice in one week
public urination cuz New York is the
greatest city on earth man okay let's
get into the news because there's so
much to discuss yeah I want to start the
past 5 on a high because Morgan Stewart
is engaged to Jordan McGraw son of dr.
Phil McGraw yes lots of people don't
know that he is a doctor himself and he
is the son of the doctor dr. Phil
Chapman and I just have somet so many
happy thoughts about this I mean my
first thought is like Brendan just must
be vomiting because for those who don't
know Jordan and Morgan actually dated
before she was married to Brendan
so he was like the guy Morgan told
Brendan not to worry about for sure and
now they're now they're divorced and
like she's engaged now he's very much
worried and I'm sure he's just like
thinking like oh my god my whole
marriage like it was a lie for sure was
my whole marriage was like the the set
up yeah this happily ever after to me
like Jordan McGraw has like the most
impeccable taste in women you know what
I mean cuz like if you can land Morgan
Stewart to me she's one of the most
eligible bachelorettes in the world not
even just Hollywood like in the world
first well she's so stunning she's so
smart she's so successful on her own
she's his fabulous personality she's so
stylish like I can't name one bad thing
about her the definition of everything
of the sort when you look it up in the
dictionary yes everything of the sort
she's also the definition of it girl
like that is her right now for sure and
I just loved there's so many things that
I love about that ok this is what I love
about it first and foremost and I love
how much it like shocked and stunned me
and how much it stuck with me for a few
days
oh my god I woke up in the morning I'm
like do you know by the way literally
same and I actually spoke to Morgan and
she said she was like completely behind
sided she had absolutely no idea which
is just even more beautiful like that
that's what an it girl deserves like
just to be blindsided 100% and let's
just go back to March when we started
quarantine and that's when
they came out with their relationship as
they were going to be together doing
Instagram I from home and so like over
the course of quarantine ESA started
dating before but it couldn't have been
that long they like we're living
together got engaged and are gonna live
happily ever Arsene now like they went
from zero to 100 yeah I mean quarantine
and that's called making the most of the
situation right we said before
quarantine there's only two ways that
this could go
there's the Kacey Musgraves route and
there's the Morgan Stewart route and I'm
just so happy for Morgan Stewart there's
so many elements of this that bring me
joy the first is like I am just happy
for Morgan Stewart becoming a member of
this rich Hollywood family like dr. Phil
money is money like he has been on the
air for years and years and years he was
radio he has a podcast now he's just so
successful and I love her being becoming
a part of like an institution in
Hollywood to me that makes me so happy
the other element that I love about this
is that Jordan McGraw is like weirdly um
like a part of the Jonas family and this
would make Morgan Stewart like a Jake
cousin not a J sister she's like Jake
has it in her first shirt right yeah cuz
I smell like Priyanka commented did she
sure yeah Oh oh my god the elegance but
that's also what I love about Morgan
Stewart she's like a relatable queen who
like answered my text when I was like
are you engaged but then also Priyanka
Chopra is commenting on her Instagram
like we have no choice but to respect a
queen he she commented on Jordans
Instagram does not anything we've no
choice but to respect a queen who is
everything of the sort
I just I'm like weirdly obsessive and I
also really like the fact that he's a
musician and his songs are really good
yes I mean that's just must be like
really attractive for her yeah and I'm
just I'm so here for all of it oh also
as I was researching this morning this
is crazy
news that I was wondering about because
I saw that she was moving because she
was dismantling her amazing closet and I
was like wondering where she was moving
to and then she got engaged shows
assuming she was moving in with her
man's um and apparently dr. Phil McGraw
bought his son a ten million dollar home
after he got engaged to Morgan Stewart
okay Jordan McGraw has a lot to
celebrate this July in addition to
becoming engaged to e-news his very own
Morgan Stewart the son of dr. Phil will
be moving into a spanking new 10 million
dollar home according to Variety the
Beverly Hills mansion was gifted to
Jordan by his parents Robin McGraw and
dr. Phil his
6500 square foot estate is situated on
the hillside of one of Beverly Hills
most exclusive neighborhoods it comes
complete with all the amenities one
could meet and more including a pool
wine room and outdoor kitchen moreover
he will have plenty of space to
entertain or host guests with Corvettes
and four and a half baths perfect one
for each Joe his brother wait I like
this house is like making my life I
don't know why he sees those pictures
well now it begs the question this isn't
the house that went viral of dr. Phil
member when people he put one of his
house up houses up for sale and the
interior was really questionable and it
totally went pirate oh my god this house
you guys will post pictures on our
Instagram marble fireplace wine cellar
thickening ocean firm gemin oh my god I
am over the moon like this is just this
is the life I envisioned for Morgan
Stewart like I know I'm Morten Stewart
like probably has a lot of expectations
for herself for career and personal life
but I have some too and this is just
like totally exceeding those
expectations I'm like so happy for her
that she's gonna live in this 10 million
dollar house and just be the fabulous
queen that she is hundred percent I just
I don't know I feel like an investor in
Morgan Stewart's life like I obviously
saw her on richkids of Beverly Hills and
obviously she was my favorite
she was funniest and then she just like
morph to this like reality show and took
a full-fledged career and now she's just
out here killing it living in a ten
million dollar house and she's so
inspiring
yes I love her so much I'm so happy and
I love how happy collectively like the
world was for this everyone was we were
rooting for you we were all rooting for
you like everyone was rooting for you
I've never yelled at a girl like this
and it was just beautiful yeah really
beautiful unfortunately I do have to
switch gears Oh
splitsville news oh my god because Kacey
Musgraves in rust and Kelly have split
they have reached the end of their
rainbow the country singer and her
singer-songwriter husband have called it
quits after over two years of marriage
their reps confirmed to people on Friday
quote these kinds of announcements are
always met with scrutiny and speculation
and we want to stop that before it even
starts their joint statement bread we
believe that we were put into each
other's lives for a divine reason and
have both changed each other infinitely
for the better the love we have for each
other goes far beyond the relationship
we've shared as husband and wife it's a
soul connection that can never be erased
okay they definitely wrote this
statement that publicist using the word
soul connection you know
but like they're speaking so highly of
each other I just don't understand how
this equates to divorce I know and you
know what it's like why am I so shocked
but also not chalk people have
questioned her marriage forever and it
used to just be this annoying thing
where it's like leave her alone she
likes to keep her marriage private but
at the end of the day the people
questioning it were kind of right
because here we are I'm just I'm shocked
because when they did decide to get
married it just seems so real and it was
like OTP and I kind of loved it they
kept to private and everyone thought
they weren't together but they always
we're like they were spotted at Target
you know like there was something about
the mystery that really made me feel
like their love was real but then at the
same time you know she's had this
amazing year and he was not present for
any of it like he wasn't at the Grammys
he wasn't maybe he was he was when she
was like yeah and she he took her purse
yeah it was just I don't know it's just
I hate to say it but it's like she kind
of just outgrew him well that seems like
the surface reason you know what we see
of their relationship shows us that she
obviously just like shot to start him in
the last two years hmm I'm mega stardom
she's always been a star boy well to me
she's always been a star but now like
the world bandwagon fans are like now
she's like mega she's an institution
everything where it's like she was a
star before yeah um and so the way we
see it it's like obviously these two
things don't add up but you never know
what goes on and this statement is one
of the more confusing ones it's like
they knew that we are getting bored by
these um template divorce statements
yeah but it's so they threw a wrench
into it all so it's like they wanted
this statement you just like not confuse
anyone in the sense that like they never
wanted it to seem like someone cheated
because that's always what people think
especially when like such a short
marriage like why why ow
so I don't think anyone cheated and I
think that's what this statement was
trying to convey convey yeah yeah or
avoid it also adds we've made this
painful decision together a healthy
decision that comes after a very long
period of trying the best we can it
simply just didn't work though we are
parting ways in marriage we will mean we
will remain true friends for the rest of
our lives I feel like true friends for
the rest guys that's that's a marriage
you could hope for
no that's literally a marriage I think
here's where I feel I am you know are no
one can even argue Kacey Musgraves
number one fan so I feel very sad that
this is obviously like a painful thing
you know divorce is so hard they say
it's like a death you know member
Shannon and David beador burying Shannon
it's painful of course but at the same
time like I just know that this album is
going to be heartbreaking and I feel
like that's what we need from Kacey
Musgraves like she's gonna win another
Grammy whatever art comes out of
quarantine divorce she says she likes to
experiment with LSD when she does
creative writing sessions like I just
think all of these elements are going to
birth the greatest album of all time I
really feel that way I set it here right
now July 7th 2020 we'll see what happens
in a year if I was right I probably am
okay I know everyone like loves to say
that when there was like someone goes
through it but not everyone knows that a
battle yes but nobody says it like a P V
Rex I you know like certain people that
convey certain emotions and Adele and
Kacey Musgraves are the del Kacey
Musgraves Kelly Clarkson but I just want
to say like golden hour was written when
she was happily married and worked well
at the beginning of her marriage happy
and sad at the same time maybe she
wasn't okay maybe that's why it was so
brilliant it's written at a high and
it's one of the greatest albums of all
time you know but by the way I'm not
saying only heartbreak is good for
creative outlets highs and lows are good
that's why Golden Hour was so fabulous
she had just got married
of course I'm sad she's going through a
low time right now but I'm just excited
for the fruits of the low yeah okay the
fruits of 2019 labor yes thank you
jackie quoted my comment special
intentions I just wanted to say I feel
as though like right now my heart goes
out to Kacey Musgraves but I feel like
when a celebrity especially at really
private celebrities like these to make a
statement like this it comes really
after the decision has been made in the
hurt has transpired so I feel like she's
probably doing okay right now now let's
play our favorite game of who do we set
her up with because San Twitter is
convinced that like this is a result of
a tawdry love affair with Harry Styles
because you know they've toured together
and then she brought him out at her
Nashville show they have like a long
history they have a deep respect
musically for one another I don't know
if I see it as a love relationship but
I'm definitely not opposed to it I have
a man for her who and I think you're
gonna love it I just need him to really
be the reformed man that he says that he
is John Mayer oh my god
that is sickening sickening except I
feel like Kacey Musgraves is too much of
like a self respected feminist to really
be with someone who has
proved more often than not that he's
just not it for women you know he's not
like he's not like like a voice for
women you know yeah well but by the way
I love that so much and then like I
could just hear the harmonies of the
collabs the harmonies but she does like
a more low-key guy I don't think she'll
date someone famous
she likes the musician clearly um who's
sort of maybe a songwriter she's needy a
producer she's had a very strange love
life now that I think about it because
she and me yes she that's why this was
so crazy like because she cuz it
happened so fast she with that eating
her her then mate forever and then one
day they broke up the next day she took
he took his Nissan Sentra according to
her song and got the [ __ ] out space
cowboy and then she's married five
seconds later and so when that happens
you assume that it's the one true pair
yeah and it like was if she hadn't
gotten so famous like I'm convinced fame
really ruins a lot of things and the
level that she shot to you over the last
year and a half is just so astronomical
that I don't think really any marriage
that started before it could ever
survive especially when the other person
is a musician not to say he was jealous
but competition is an inherent part of
being successful and I just can't
imagine that it didn't cause some sort
of conversation like she went to the
Kardashian Halloween party by herself
like yeah there's just there's there was
so much to unpack and all I want to do
is like spend the next ten years
thinking about who she's gonna date
because now that you brought up John
Mayer like I just can't think of
anything else but at the same time
you're right she does like someone way
more low-key and they feel like she may
be one of those people I feel like a lot
of people find really solid Hollywood
marriage is when they you know end up
with like their agent or like someone in
the biz but not like in the spotlight
like yes Witherspoon has been married
now for like 20 years to her agent so I
feel like there's something there for
sure
this is devastating but again the album
is it is coming yeah um you know what
else is coming yeah
today sponsor policy genius there's
never a bad time to save money that is
true but now more than ever finding
smart ways to put some cash back in your
pocket can make a huge difference one
way to do that is simply want me to do
that is to simply save on things you
already pay for like home
pterence if you own a home if your rish
opping your home insurance rates with
policy genius you could save a good
chunk of change and the best part is you
barely need to lift a finger first head
to policy genius comm and answer a few
quick questions about yourself and your
property the policy genius will compare
your policy against options from top
insurers to make sure you're getting the
right home insurance coverage at the
best possible price if policy genius
finds you a better rate than what you're
currently paying they'll do all the work
to get you switched if you own a car to
policy genius will compare your home and
auto policies across different insurers
and even mix and match to find you
savings they've saved their customers an
average of a thousand one hundred and
twenty seven dollars per year just by
doing that so if you'd like to put a
little cash back in your pocket right
now which everyone needs see how much
you can save by reshaping your home
insurance at policy genius.com that's
policy genius.com
to reshape your home insurance rates
policy genius.com
thank you policy genius for being
today's sponsor love it okay next story
very sad news Nick Cordero Broadway star
of waitress and a bronze tale has died
at the age of 41
Nick Cordero the Broadway actor who
appeared in popular musicals such as
waitress and a Bronx Tale and inspired
the world with his month-long struggle
against the coronavirus has died his
wife Amanda cludes said on Sunday oh my
god was 41 she wrote on Instagram quote
God has another angel in heaven now my
darling husband passed away this morning
he was surrounded and loved by his
family singing and praying as he gently
left this earth oh my god I mean a lot
of people have been following this story
for so long and I think what's been so
amazing about this story is like his
wife's ability to never give up hope
when it's like she's going through the
toughest times in her life
she's a brand-new baby her husband's
been in the hospital for months fighting
coronavirus and it's just it's literally
the saddest thing ever and I can't
believe that like after all of this that
he lost the battle and I'm just so sad
for her but like I still am in awe of
like her her civilian spirit like she's
still on Instagram dancing for him and
it's like it's just it's really like a
beautiful way to deal with grief I'm
just like so sad for her and her baby
and I just can't believe like after all
of this like this is how the story ended
you know it's really sad it's really
really sad and I just I didn't really
know much about her before but
I just like love her now and I want to
protect her and there's so many people
who feel that way like I saw he's a very
well-respected person in the Broadway
community and so many huge Broadway
people we're tweeting about it and
there's like a fund that's been set up
for them I think it's almost a million
dollars and obviously oh that's amazing
but it's just it doesn't bring back her
husband and the father of her baby and I
just I'm so sad yeah there's been a lot
of outreach and statements from
celebrities who have worked with him he
clearly was such a light that's how
really everyone describes him and this
is incredibly tragic it's just it's
terrible and you know he's 41 years old
that's just not what you expect to hear
and it's just a reminder that life is so
short and the coronavirus is a little
[ __ ] and everyone should wear a mask
yeah definitely
I'm like really just it's weird to feel
so impacted by a story of people you
don't know but that's what she did
during this time when she was just
trying to rally people to like pray for
him and dance for him and I sort of
learned that's in their family yeah yeah
well it's very sad we're thinking of her
and her baby
yeah um next story little mindless new
relationship news fabulous Chris Evans
and Lily James spark dating rumors with
late-night London picks Captain America
yeah Chris Evans yeah yes
nods out yeah okay we'll start using
that reference knives out oh so I
shouldn't show you something Instagram
story last night I was watching the wall
which is literally the best [ __ ] game
show it's on NBC and I saw I saw you're
thinking this girl had to answer a
trivia and it was like which one of
these Chris's has been in Marvel blah
blah it was like Chris Evans Chris Pine
Chris Pratt and then Chris Hemsworth
which I knew it wasn't Chris Hemsworth
that's like the one that I know but it
was just so fun whoever he's guardians
of the out no it's not Chris Pratt it
was Chris Evans I I think
but whoever you know was writing trivia
for the wall on every see obviously
listens to the shows did not the moral
of the story hey um but Chris Evans and
Lily James may be the newest extremely
good-looking couple in Hollywood as the
UK's Daily Mail has photos of the pair
sharing a taxi late Saturday in London
yes I saw like there was literally 6
a.m. vibes which I love who love to see
it the pair spent the bulk of the
evening at the ritzy after-hours marks
Club in Mayfair with James in a red
dress for the occasion and Evans opting
for an all-black suit
Lulla James is like one of the most
random beautiful women you know what I
mean like she's not really like super
famous she was shot to stardom in the
Cinderella movie that really just didn't
shoot her anywhere besides down I know I
haven't reported I've been meaning to
catch it and she's just like such a
strange kind of phenomena to me cuz like
she was really positioned to become like
this huge star and it just really never
happened for her I don't know she's
she's a moderate star she is now Mamiya
oh that's true he was in the worst movie
of all time called yesterday Oh was she
the Beatles Munn she obviously doesn't
have a good radar for which projects to
take because she's in things I've heard
of but never seen I guess this also
means that she can sing because it's
true she just gives me a vibe like she
should have been in Game of Thrones for
sure I'm sure she's in you know what
let's look at her IMDB but also just to
talk about these two I think this is a
fabulous couple I love when beautiful
beautiful people just like get together
and they sync up and yeah and share
calendars and they do the work for us I
get in have to match these two together
like they just they work perfectly
together do we think they're gonna be
together forever and get married no
family and children no but do I love
this one nightstand yes yes oh she was
in Pride and Prejudice and Zombies wait
Pride and Prejudice comma zombies are
Pride and like one movie run one movie
Pride and Prejudice and Zombies is one
yeah oh she's in Downton Abbey that know
that that's what launched her but see
that's what I'm saying I feel like there
was a few years where I was like the
Lily James time like she was gonna be it
after Downton Abbey and then she got
Cinderella and it was like supposed to
be this foundational thing for her and I
just feel like she never really
delivered in that kind of success you
know I need to watch that movie because
I feel like I would love it yeah but I
don't know why I've never seen it well
so funny when I read this story for some
reason it registered for me as Lily
Collins okay which is just so ironic
because wasn't she in the other
Cinderella she was in the other Snow
White oh yeah yeah that Harry mirror and
then there was Snow White and the
Huntsman Kristen Stewart yeah Chris
Hemsworth that was a weird time in
Disney when they were just making two
movies at a time ya know it's like this
story has been around since like the
dawn of time yeah you couldn't have made
them at a different year no you couldn't
have
they couldn't have okay fifth and final
story your day
kazeem Maxwell update Jelena Jelena and
just Lane jillaine Maxwell has copies of
Jeffrey Epstein sex tape ex-friends says
okay Jolene has been all over the news
she was arrested now the New York Post
is saying she is going to sing for her
supper and just give all the details she
wants to know that the police wants to
know just so she can get a lesser
sentence and as many people probably
know if you watch the Jeffrey Epstein
documentary probably the person who has
the most information on this entire ring
more so than Jeffrey Epstein I would say
is ghilane because she was the madam she
was the procurator of young women she
was the secretary of the institution she
kept all the files they say that she has
written record of every you know
powerful person who did X Y & Z and she
really is the most dangerous but to me
there's so much injustice in Jeffrey
Epstein not having his day in court
but to me the one who could really you
know break down the whole thing more is
Golay yes I agree she's our last hope of
really getting justice for these girls
he's meant for this case and I don't
have a lot of hope as her being our last
resort because the craziest thing
happened and I'm not sure how some
people saw it because it was taken down
you share this with the class I find
this quite interests on the BBC released
an article and immediately deleted it
and it was an article scheduled for July
11th 2020 and this was on July I think
fifth so obviously it's a week early and
the headline says geez Lainie Maxwell
moved to intensive care as coronavirus
symptoms worsen so it has yet to be even
reported that she has coronavirus so
this this makes me question you know
everything everything because they're
obviously planning a new cycle that
reports on her eventually dying of
coronavirus right she's in intensive
care she has coronavirus this does not
bode well for the success of this story
no no it doesn't it's and they deleted
it immediately and I don't think they
even released a statement but it's just
sometimes things happen
we're articles get published early and
it really releases a window into like
how corrupt everything is like do you
remember when John and Camille Shana
Camilla there was like this just not
just Herod one of these places released
an article like Sean and Camilla seen
cuddling up backstage at the VMAs it was
like Sean and Camilla - a steamy onstage
performance of senorita it was before
the award show even air yes but here's
the thing there's two things happening
one it was like that publication knew
that Sean and Camilla were seeing
segorita it's gonna be steamy because
they're all about PDA so they wrote the
article in anticipation anticipation so
they didn't have to do the legwork on
the day because they have a lot of our
articles to write during an award show
that is a thing that publications do I'm
sure they would have changed it if the
article didn't happen to come out and
elect it and no and it wasn't correct
like say they weren't steamy where you
know she like shot out of the cannon
right they were doing prep yeah they
were doing prep this feels different
this feel and like people like also some
publications have obituaries written for
people who haven't died yet yes you know
but then by the way those are the
craziest when like news channels
accidentally run the obituary of like
they have obituaries for just old people
they have it ready so that if the person
dies unexpectedly like they have the
news on it it's kind of morbid but it's
just a part of the news but sometimes
like those packages take a while to
produce if it's a montage of someone's
life you know so that's just part of
their job whatever this feels like a
story this isn't the next logical step
in this story yeah that she goes to the
ICU of course no end the BBC news like
the UK writing it up it's just it's all
too weird she is British ghilane her
father was like a media mogul disgrace
to media mogul but a media mogul
nonetheless he's king yes literally a
disgraced King and he obviously had a
very you know deeper connection said I'm
sure she inherited and just it's all
it's all too weird and it's all adding
up oh and now what's going around is
this crazy conspiracy theory about
Jelena that um in the last photo ever
taken of JonBenet Ramsay there is a
woman in the background and admittedly
only half of her face is in there but
she looks a lot like just Lanie Maxwell
and it is eerily creepy that this young
girl goes
missing and ghilane Maxwell is in the
background I don't know if it's true
there's no real confirmation
fact-checker if that is in fact her in
the background of the photo but it just
of course gives you something to think
about
nah I mean it's a funny tape talk but it
doesn't make any sense at all I don't
know I had not I'm gonna choose not to
believe it but it was a funny first
impact I think it's 100% possible and
I'm not I'm not not convinced okay um
but also as in regards to the BBC like
yes she's connected whatever but like I
thought that we're in a point right now
where like no one is striving to protect
Jeffrey Epstein and glean that's the
public's message but again that's why
this story is so crazy it's because and
that's what I didn't like about the
documentary is like they didn't even
scratch the surface at how deep this
goes from like politicians world leaders
celebrities billionaires everyone who
was involved and they can make anyone
disappear they can make these the most
powerful people in the world can do
whatever they want so it's like this is
happening all over again I'm telling you
like we are in we are gonna witness
something happen to Jelena that's crazy
it's insane and it's just how dumb do
they think we aren't it's like they
don't even care it's like the most
powerful people in the world know that
we know what they know but they just
don't want it coming out I don't know I
I hear you but like I'm just more
hopeful that the system won't fail us
won't fail us so I'm gonna choose to
believe in the system yeah and that
justice will be served she could
technically like get out on bail until
her trial but she's a huge flight risk
she has unlimited resources if she got
out of the country she would never come
back she might not be able to get right
no it's just um it's crazy it's crazy um
so anyways the story was that she has
the tapes and the tea and she's gonna
and everything she said they say she's
gonna give it up I have one more
question about this saga that is really
bothering me and that is why have we not
seen a mug shot of her Delaney I don't
know it's been weird like you got
arrested to get a mug shot it becomes
public record like why is she different
I don't know hmm makes you think I've
seen it I went searching for it makes
you think
yeah well we'll keep you updated all
week on what's going on in the Jelena
Maxwell story it's just it's honestly so
crazy it's very crazy I'm but I do look
forward to justice being served I am
very much looking forward to justice
being served and now we are moving on to
our TV recap segment we have tons to
recap including our test movie of the
week which was Selma and we are going to
do that but before that our TV recap
segment is brought to you by liquid IV
Believe It or Not dehydration occurs
daily and three out of four people with
liquid IV you have the fastest most
efficient way to stay hydrated each
serving helps you get as much hydration
as two to three bottles of water and by
the way it when I was outside this
weekend like it was just so hot and I
kept forgetting to drink water um and I
brought my liquid I'd be with me it was
just so much more efficient and time
effective to drink like what IV and it
makes you feel so great and it's great
for hangovers but that's not technically
what they're known for
proper hydration is crucial for your
immune system and it can boost your
immunity so with liquid IV you have the
fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated it's backed with potassium
vitamin C and other vitamins to help you
to help your body defend against
infections proper hydration is known to
boost your immunity so one serving of
liquid IV provides the same hydration as
drinking two to three bottles of water
alone if you have trouble drinking water
like me liquid IV is the product for you
because it also contains five essential
vitamins more it has more vitamin C than
an orange and as much potassium as a
banana if you hate eating fruit liquid
IV might be for you healthier than
sugary sports drinks no artificial
flavors or preservatives and it has less
sugar than an apple it's also made with
clean ingredients it is non-gmo vegan
and free of gluten dairy and soy what
makes it so effective is the ctt the
cellular transport technology which is
the optimal ratio of glucose sodium and
potassium they deliver water faster and
they deliver water and nutrients faster
into your bloodstream it is the perfect
balance to help you hydrate more quickly
and more effectively than water alone
plus they're on a mission to change the
world
liquid IV is donating 2.3 million
servings in response to Coba 19 products
are being donated to hospitals first
responders food banks veterans and
active military which is amazing thank
you liquid IV for doing that so you know
if you buy liquid IV you are also making
a difference which is fabulous it's a
great way to spend your cash liquid IV
is available nationwide at Costco and
Target or you can get a 25% off when you
liquid I be calm and use the code toast
at checkout so again that's liquid IV
dot-com code toast at checkout for 25%
off that's 25% off anything you water
when you use promo code toast at liquid
IV dot-com get better hydration today at
liquid I be calm promo code toast I love
it sign on get hydrated why did you give
me a weird look when I was doing the ad
I didn't know you gave me like some eyes
I thought I did something wrong no no I
was just looking at you so afraid of you
it was something I said no no you were
perfect
okay fine get hydrated TV recap our TV
movie that we assigned last week was
Selma as you guys know we are trying to
do a better job of just opening our
horizons and learning more about
experiences different than ours and our
history and I thought someone was a
great choice to be honest I was
disappointed in a few ways one was just
that um why wasn't the song glory played
sooner than the credits which is like
which is a thing now it's like if a
popular artist makes a song for a movie
they just play it in the credits and
that's not enough no it's not meant for
the actual movie it's meant for like the
promotion of the movie enjoy but you
know what the song that they played at
the end when they put um the title I
footage over the end of the March I
absolutely love that song I need to look
it up like that part was so powerful I
loved that they put the historical
footage in there and kind of you
couldn't tell which was yet the guy who
played Martin Luther King looked so much
like him yeah he did an amazing job
amazing job I liked how the movie was
like obviously about the movement of
Selma but you also got like a little
personal with MLK and his marriage like
there was just so much going on there
the other thing I didn't like about the
movie was Cuba Gooding jr. as presents
obviously I'm very triggered by that but
he was a small part in it in a good
movie I think that the story is so um so
unbelievable and it's not really taught
in depth in history classes in America
because obviously I knew about the Selma
March but I didn't know that all that
went into leading up to I didn't know
that they did it multiple times looks
like post the civil right right bill
they had to technically had the right to
vote but no one was letting them vote
right so it really was interesting so I
think it was actually a great piece of
history to focus on I'm sure there's
like so many movies they could write
this time in Martin Luther King and all
of his work and I really enjoyed this
movie like from a historical perspective
it was also so well done like in the
beginning when those girls were walking
down the steps of the church like
talking about the granite yeah yeah um
and then the church blew up I wasn't
shocked no no first of all like the
sound like blew out like literally me
and theo both jumped it was just it was
a very powerful way to start the meeting
and just that's what this whole movement
was for like just for innocent beautiful
children getting attacked for no [ __ ]
reason like yeah that was I think a
great way to start the movie I totally
agree what I really like I like two
things about the movie well I liked a
bunch of things but two things that
stood out to me was obviously um as a
citizen of America it is your right to
vote and everyone should have that right
and it shouldn't be so hard and it
shouldn't be so expensive but what I
really liked that I didn't even fully
understand was they they discussed how
obviously having a vote is important but
why also why it's important it's because
you cannot be on a member of a jury if
you are not registered to vote so it's
like all these people whether it's you
know crazy Klansmen or racist cops just
shooting black people in cold blood and
then getting off because the jury is all
white people
it looks like it's it's more than just
casting a vote it's becoming a part of
the system yeah and helping and even
just like voting in your local elections
voting for that sheriff who got voted
out the next year of the second that
they gave black people in Alabama the
right to vote we got voted out right it
really stresses the importance of voting
for on all that on all levels yeah I
agree
another thing that I loved was and he
wasn't really such a main character and
he didn't get a little blurb at the end
but Porsha Williams his grandfather was
in the movie well he not him his
character I meant to look up who
everyone was because also I was
wondering like if Jews outside was in
right no I'm sure that he was but Hosea
Williams was the leader of when they did
the first march on Selma and Martin
Luther King couldn't go yeah and those
two guys led it there was like the
student guy and then the older kind of
chubby or guy that is Hosea Williams
that is Porsha Williams his grandfather
Wow
is amazing I know and by the way the guy
who played him looked just like him when
I was looking up old photos I'm like is
that the except from the movie or from
real sama they looked so much alike it
was crazy
wow that is so interesting I know very
cool I thought it was a great movie I
really really liked it yeah and I think
that um and I liked the way that it was
done um like the they were just like a
lot of powerful moments similar to the
one in the church where just like I just
had to like stop and pause and um and so
I thought that Ava do Barney didn't a
fabulous fabulous job she's a fabulous
filmmaker one more thing I wanted to say
about the movie and about history which
obviously I'm not a history buff so I
didn't know but I just think it was
that's saying thank you it goes that
saying like LBJ sucks like of course he
did the right thing there were so many
[ __ ] shitty people LBJ was just though
worse like [ __ ] him and it's like he won
they said he was like had them one of
the biggest landslides in presidential
history I'm like this [ __ ] guy's a
[ __ ] coward and yes he did the right
thing at the end but was because he had
no other choice but yeah he was just
like a little piece of [ __ ] and he knew
it was the right thing to do and that's
what what I took away from the movie was
like politics is such [ __ ] because
it's really never about doing the right
thing it's always someone's personal
stake an interest of a lobby or whatever
it's like their supporters or your your
donators like it just it was really
disappointing to see like so many people
know that they could have the power to
do the right thing and not do it because
of politics like politics is just
[ __ ] LBJ sucks
yeah I mean also George Wallace the
governor oh the biggest dick alive oh
and then he ran for president four times
and couldn't win like literally a rotten
hail literally I hate that guy I 100
percent also this movie had a message
that's been very similar to a lot of the
other stuff that we were watching which
is that the FBI is the [ __ ] Road and
also like the way they were logging all
of their activity was just so blatantly
racist like they're just the way they
spoke I was like damn yeah and that FBI
director who's Jay Edgar who yes who's
like it's all named after him
oh and it's like Shaddai it's very sad I
know it's just like history watching it
and going back in our history just shows
you like everything's [ __ ] up and
everyone's [ __ ] up and it was a great
movie it was a great movie and it just
really highlighted for me like how
politics is just [ __ ] yeah but why
is it so hard
to get something done when it's the
right thing to do like it shouldn't have
taken thousands of people literally
getting beaten in marching 50 miles and
having to do it three times just to get
it shouldn't have been that hard yeah so
and you know what what I've really
learned from all of these movies is how
creepy it is to me how a lot of these
movies are either made a while ago or
about things that happened a while ago
and it really feels like the stories
could have been told today like it
doesn't feel like that much has changed
you know yeah so I liked it I hope
everyone else liked it and we really I
really really liked it we have a great
movie for our next selection I thought
it would be good maybe just lighten
things up a little bit and go back to a
movie that honestly really impacted me
as a child it's called the color of
friendship it is a Disney Channel
original movie I believe it is on Disney
Plus for free and honestly if you have
kids and you are a toaster I would
really recommend you watch it with your
kids it's just a fabulous movie about
the color of friendship it's just it's
self explanatory honestly but um I
remember watching it as a kid and just
like loving it so much and I think it'll
be great like a nostalgic moment for us
and a really good opportunity if you
have kids too or like younger siblings
to have them watch it it's a really good
movie I'm excited yeah great okay um I
want to talk also in our TV recap about
the David Foster document yeah I watched
it last night at your request very glad
I did I probably would have watched it
anyway but I sped up the process yeah we
can discuss it today I took a few things
away from it the first thing I took away
was I really didn't realize how old
David Foster was because when he's
talking about like working with Jennifer
Holliday coming up this man is old and
he's been and he's been successful for
so long you know and of course you know
about the Josh Groban the Celine Dion
anybody talk about to me too what you
don't really know is like the Chicago or
you know the Jennifer Holliday I go yeah
like it's just first of all I loved I
think that the documentary did an
amazing job of like being like let's put
some respect on this man's name like he
is it yeah and you know what it's like I
don't the company that made the
documentary did a fabulous job I have to
believe that someone in there ID aiding
was a toaster because this is what we've
been striving for for years now which is
justice for David Foster we've been
saying it since day one Dave since day
one because of the wet like and they
talk about it a little bit when he talks
real houses Beverly Hills when it's like
oh you're the guy who was on realism
right he's like no I'm the guy who's won
16 Grammys yes also somebody sent me
Indy and they're like I'm listening to
old episodes of the toast like from a
year ago and you guys literally said
David Foster needs a documentary
you said crazy no I'm telling you like
it was just like from our mouth to the
documentarians ears so that was the
first part that I loved I also loved how
much footage they had of just like old
saline moments and all these fabulous
artists and it was just like really like
a beautiful artistically done
documentary which I loved
agreed I loved the fact that they put up
the foster family chart which has become
iconic like pop culture Canon yep and
that is something that you must um
understand must understand he also
forgot to name Anwar but they put him in
yes I saw that too
and okay there's so much today I want to
talk about in regards to that moment to
me it is so clear like that the Fosters
just like hate Yolanda and I think and
it probably has to do with the fact that
maybe she didn't say it in so many words
but she let everyone think that David
left her because she had money my god
I'm so sorry oh my god I'm so sorry that
was a total fuck-up I'm so sorry I
really didn't mean to say that that was
incredibly rude um I it's from I was
just watching that episode of Real
Housewives I'm so sorry um because she
had Lyme's disease and they like he she
really let the world like turn him into
a villain because of that and I'm sure
that that they're not happy about that
I'm also sure that some of the girls are
a little resentful that Yolanda went on
that show and made a star out of her
daughters in five minutes while Sarah
and Aaron have been working in Hollywood
for years they had barely famous like
they've been working on in industry for
so long and like you want to just shows
up with her two kids and like overnight
it's a success yeah I went to bed last
night wondering if Gigi and Bella would
be who they are if not for the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills and up until
this point I always said they would have
been like I didn't even think about how
it might have helped them in any way
because it was just sort of like it just
seemed like good timing but now I'm
unsure know I've always thought that the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills was an
integral part in the making of two major
mega super models and they probably
would have become successful regardless
just because they're beautiful and from
a
rich well-connected family are plenty of
like rich kid model Delilah and Amelia
yeah there's a ton of people like that
yeah but also they have Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills but I guess they also
had it because there are Delilah and
Amelia and they're not ggm Ella right so
it's a mixture of things yes but it
definitely played a part so to me what I
really took away from the documentary is
just like this kind of hatred for
Yolanda even in the way they just spoke
about her very calmly but very rudely
like when the younger sister Jordan
Foster was like and you know my dad was
okay with her being on the Housewives
cuz you know he wanted her to have a job
which was just like a holy [ __ ] like
they just there's obvious like hatred
there oh for sure for sure but I think
that they were as respectful as they
could have be you know they didn't harp
on it they didn't talk about her out of
no context so I but I forgot about the
princess of Malibu I know and I had
obviously never seen it and like the
fact that David is such an integral part
like yelling at everyone the entire time
yeah um was really funny and I actually
would have thought that that would
affect his career in a negative way
because it seems like it was kind of a
[ __ ] show right and so what I took away
from the documentary was like David it's
actually very self-aware and he knew
like even just kind of quote-unquote
slumming it in reality TV like was not
gonna affect his career like with Stevie
Wonder still want to work with me if I
was on the Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills but you know what his talent
speaks for itself and I feel like at the
end of the day like nobody cared about
anything when it came to David Foster
other than the fact that he made great
music for great people and won a lot of
awards and that's really all that
matters at the end of the day but his
self-awareness was was really present
throughout the whole documentary
especially when it came to talking about
his multiple marriages and like his
relationship with his kids which seems
like there was a lot of resentment and
that maybe hasn't been unpacked and I'm
curious what the drama was at Erin's
wedding that like Kathryn had to get
involved but it did feel weird for me to
talk so much about running and getting
comfortable than running again while
also acting like Kathryn was like in the
end-all-be-all and and it was just like
this weird underlying question for her
no but it was also this self-awareness
to be like I'm not gonna pretend like
I'm not I'm done running because that's
who I am but I also and it seems like
he's treating things differently in this
relationship and that Kathryn is a
completely different sort of partner
yeah and I think that they're so well
matched um and I think we've always like
had a little ship for them nothing big
new verse we were definitely confused
just because of the age difference but
now it's like I real and I started
looking at her on Instagram and sort of
watching these videos they've been
putting out during quarantine and I
totally I really get it also they put in
some footage from the wedding and like
what a stunningly beautiful bride I
think one of like the top 10 most
beautiful rides I've ever seen in my
life
agreed like sick to the [ __ ]
core just a beautiful wedding beautiful
dress her body like everything was body
sickening sickening um also what I like
about David Foster is he's obviously a
genius he's so beyond like talented
every isn't even more edible put in the
blender mix it up um and he doesn't even
pretend to be humble about it you know
like and I appreciate that because would
even mean oh wow it just sort of
happened I kind of do too like I just
sort of appreciate the
matter-of-factness when he's like I'm
great
yes and I feel like in order to achieve
certain levels of success you have to be
confident in your own abilities but at a
certain point like if you don't think if
you've won 16 Grammys nominated for 40
some of the biggest songs of all time
and you can't say sit there and say I'm
great then you obviously don't know what
you're doing yeah I really loved like
the little nuances and the little
stories about such big moments in pop
culture like honestly I didn't even know
that David Foster did The Bodyguard
I will always love you and like what
went into that and they got Clive Davis
they got everyone the documentary
[ __ ] Bill Clinton was in it which was
the weirdest thing ever um but I just
loved those little stories about like
decisions made in a moment with a
moment's notice
that created this huge moment for pop
culture I just I loved all those little
stories now I have one problem with the
documentary and with David Foster's
career in general and I just feel like
he really he made a big mistake with
Michael Buble like I I and you know what
I don't dislike Michael Buble I've
actually been to his concerts and I
think they're phenomenal but like to me
he is just like a glorified Vegas show
man like inator
he's a Frank Sinatra impersonator his
biggest song ever is a cover like I
don't know I just I didn't I didn't see
aside from having just like a really
good voice which a lot of people have
good voices like I don't really see what
David Foster saw in Michael Buble and I
feel like maybe that was like a bad year
from David Foster cuz like I just
wouldn't put Josh grobin on the same
pedestal as Michael Buble at all no I
don't think that he's meant to do that I
don't think I would put either one of
them on the same pedestal as Celine Dion
but what he did with Michael Buble it
doesn't matter whether you think he's
good enough or not like he created a
whole genre of like of music that people
want to listen to who aren't done
listening to Frank Sinatra yeah and want
new stuff Michael Buble is incredibly
talented yes I mean I liked him up until
that video um seeing him in the
documentary he at first I was just like
a little of such creepy I was just like
a little shook for sure I I just but
then we got to it I had no idea that
David Foster discovered him uh you know
I didn't like know it but when it
happened I was like oh that make sense
yeah I also loved that David Foster is a
Canadian who supports other Canadians
yes I always driving 100 miles to toe
I'm sorry the craziest part of the
documentary was the carnac site now I
mean first of all I'd obviously didn't
know about that and so when the story
was being told I'm like this is
incredible and then when it turned out
to be a very successful comedian who he
had I'm sorry not community a musician
who he had hit I was like holy [ __ ] and
then it turned out to be like a
life-saving hit right the guy had had
some sort of hematoma and was wandering
in the street at 7 8 at 6:00 a.m. or 2
a.m. a it was an unbelievable story
that's what I mean like David Foster the
documentary was great because he's
obviously the co well-known guy for
certain parts of his life but he's
really lived a long life and had so many
successes and triumphs and trials and
tribulations and I just thought it was a
perfect subject for a documentary and a
very well-done documentary at that
yeah um let's talk about Josh Groban
because absolutely like I've had a crush
on Josh Groban my entire life and I
guess I'd never really seen him talk on
film yeah weird yeah and then when they
showed like his catalog of work they
showed that cover the album cover it's
like black and white and he looks like a
different Oh with the beard he looked so
handsome yeah and I'm like that's not
the guy in the chair no there's - Josh
Groban's there's one who wears glasses
and lets his hair grow out and then
there's like snatched Josh Groban with a
beard and like he kind of looks like he
lives in Brooklyn and he doesn't wear
his glasses and his cheeks are very
tight yeah so I was just like shook and
now I just think of Josh Groban
completely differently like no I do not
see him with Katy Perry like I once did
no he's very nerdy
you could even tell in his in his
commentary in the interview part of the
documentary he was kind of weird yeah
honestly like ya know I don't see him
with Katy Perry at all I see him
honestly when he was dating kat dennings
like that was perfect she's also like
kind of weird and like yeah her own me
Kacey Musgraves wow that was sickening
yeah but I think she's like a little too
cool for him I know but she could like
she could raise him up he needs like a
regular girl I mean the story of like
how he got to where he is and how at
that I didn't know that he was just a
Stabler but Charlie and that's how he
was discovered but the way that Celine
Dion like kind of nurtured him just made
me love her so much I know Josh Groban
is an incredible talent okay
absolutely like it's crazy I'm what's
also crazy is that David would be like I
have this artist we're putting off this
album and put it out now it also helped
50,000 copies but to me David Foster is
very like B to B not B to C like he
doesn't up and this was before really
social media so it's not like he had
this fan base so how did he get so much
influence in sales and consumers like
we're people following just the work of
David Foster I don't know but I do think
when someone became big in his sphere it
was it was like a company like Celine
Dion would leverage a voice like Josh
Groban like it was this sort of family
yeah definitely but I just thought I was
wondering how he could I don't have so
much consumer influence when he's very
much on the industry side yeah no that's
true and how he knew he was sick he was
all about making the music but then he
also knew it would sell 50,000 units
like yeah yeah so I just I thought that
was an interesting tidbit also when he
was like doesn't want me in the studio
now cuz he doesn't think he like he's
capable of being in the room with Lady
gaga
like I actually think they would be
fabulous together and to me like that
was a dumb statement because if he
really knew anything about Lady Gaga he
would know that he she they're very
similar like she knows every hit like
she went on the road with Tony Bennett
like they had they're more alike than
they are unlike I actually think a Lady
Gaga
David Foster album could be just the
thing that this year needs like but when
he said that he would have worked on
star is born in a heartbeat like that's
also what stars born needed yes of
course I was actually shocked that he
didn't write shallow you know yeah also
like he used the wrong reference when he
meant lead
like he could have said like TV right
that's who we met and I'm bug that I
hate that I always use be back some what
I'm talking about generic pop stars
because I actually love BB wrecks and I
think she's so talented and we met her
and she was so nice and I really only
have good things to say about her but I
need yeah I mean like Ava max you know
like I need like a different name
because I love bebe Rexha I actually
respect her and I feel like every time I
like making joke about pop stars I used
her name and I want to stop doing that
yeah but um you know what I mean when
I'm a trainer yes yes but actually she's
also talent is a very talented
songwriter I take it back I mean like I
mean like I'll come up with one yeah
also I was just thinking about how David
Foster like should definitely be on song
land of course also what I thought was
interesting is that on I was looking at
some of the songs that he's written and
a lot of the songs that he's worked on
his writing credit is Linda Thompson so
she's also like a songwriter she's
credited on the biggest songs that he's
written so I just she's still cashing in
yeah I wonder what it seemed like they
had a nice life yet to be honest it
doesn't seem like he has that much like
oh he doesn't have a terrible
relationship with his his ex-wives but I
did think it was really interesting how
he said he's really his regret when it
comes to his marriage as his leaving
Rebecca who I think is Erin and Sarah's
mom yeah great
cuz that is to me when I think of like
the foster family I think of obviously
like Sarah and Erin and Jordan yeah also
I love the transparency around wanting
to be an eagle yes
and now David Foster is working on three
Broadway productions love to see it I'm
clear if I will be seeing it but right
time to bed time to transition to
Broadway it's true but it gives also him
a lot of time to work on what he's
working on I really hope my god I really
hope that tea comes down for him yes the
the weirdness with the elevators was so
interesting and honestly I've heard that
from a lot of very famous people that
they just don't take elevators and I
think the way that I see it is like a
lot of people who shot shoot to stardom
grew up at very simple lives like small
towns and if you grow up taking
elevators like it's not a big deal but
if you're an adult and you're really
thinking logistics I'm gonna get in this
moving box this is actually very
dangerous like the older you are I
actually understand not wanting to get
into an elevator but if you're a kid who
took elevators all the time
it's like not a big deal you're kind of
desensitized to it but it's something
I've seen with a few famous people that
I think is very interesting that's how I
feel about driving a car exactly like
the older you get actually the more
scary it is and the less likely you are
to actually do it yeah I agree that was
interesting as well the last thing I
want to talk about as I watch this movie
desperado on Netflix it's an epic
original it's like you know they were
releasing just like shitty content um
and it's like these three bass gal pals
at a camp was in it
and that guy was in it who is just like
the guy in every bad movie he's the guy
from Duff his name is Robbie something
oh yeah it's actually very handsome okay
oh no Robbie with an A yeah duh Robbie
Robbie Amell yeah it was just like such
a bad movie it was two hours but it was
also like kind of good I don't know I
would love to hear what everyone thinks
about it there was like so much CGI and
it was so strange like they were in
Mexico and there's like this scene where
like a dolphin like literally comes up
and like dick-slap start it makes it's
literally the dumbest thing ever but
it's so strange because it was so poorly
done CJ it was like literally it was it
was the weirdest movie it took me two
days to watch it and I really like did
not like it but also sometimes I was
like he it was really weird I don't know
if I would recommend it but it did you
know fill up some time in my day which
is all you can ask for when it comes to
quarantine very interesting maybe I'll
check it out I have so many things to
watch I just like I don't even know
where to start the kissing booth trailer
has is ah you know what I was thinking
about so strangely when it comes to the
kissing booth is the kissing booth came
out before to all the boys I loved
before but we've already seen the sequel
up to all the boys
we haven't even like we just saw the
trailer there's something so weird with
kissing booth like between the Jacob
Elora T and Joey king of it all and like
literally it's been two years I watched
the first kissing booth in my old
apartment on 32nd Street Wow it's not
weird yeah it's just there's so much
weirdness there it's like why bother now
no I mean it was a great movie and I'm
sure the sequel will be great and I'll
look forward to adding it to my list of
things I'm never getting to yes exactly
and on that note that's all she wrote
yeah I said one thing ready for a while
actually yeah I think you guys so much
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where you live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so every watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that Spotify
iTunes stitcher public radio IRS
bucks all the places whoever you listen
to podcast by this morning toast million
five-star view about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys very much we hope you have a
fabulous day we will see you tomorrow
bye